imagine struggling to speak not being
able to say help or I love you no need
to get emotional I know but it's what
happens we can't avoid that Barbara used
to be a professor
her brain is still sharp but motor
neuron disease makes talking tough and
one of the few who understands Barbara
is her carer Laura Cara is clearly a
very important part of Barbara's life
caterers are a very important part of
your life without a day I mean I spend
five hours alone with her on a Friday
afternoon because she is socially
isolated and scared about contracting
coronavirus doctors would end up to
choose who would live in New Britain and
she knows she would be one of the ones
that this teenage so but it's not going
to cause we're on the ball okay now
you've got me and you haven't done that
in a while
my husband Gordon died from the same
condition at the age of 31 by the end of
his life he used a wheelchair needed to
be fed and would drink through a straw
and it was this team of carers who over
the years became our friends but this
care company is small and the boss
Andrea had text to me that she was
worried what might happen if someone
became ill I don't mean to sound a
motivator but we are terrified or if one
staff member calls or felt we've still
got to provide exactly the same service
to the other clients and so if one staff
member gate so that's a problem if five
staff members get ill yes
that's that's delicious well the company
has spent thousands of pounds buying
protective gloves but has found it
difficult to buy masks and hand
sanitizer for those sent out to people's
homes the people you're looking after
often maybe don't see any one day today
some of them have family at all the GAR
selves that go on
more than 800,000 people rely on home
care across the UK including for washing
eating and going to the bathroom
reducing pressure on the NHS Jim and his
wife Annette are concerned about the
impact on them if schools closed now
what do the clearest you or anybody
that's so working are looming for
instance what are they doing their
children don't know but school nobody to
go and the threat of coronavirus has
left them feeling anxious
well yeah bit my family oh yeah Big Jim
yeah there is that okay for you for now
Laura continues caring for Barbara
but they both hope when the system is
under strain they won't be forgotten Joe
Pike Sky News Edinburgh